ayant mais ma chérie tu sais que je
respecte complètement enfin musique
mais le problème c'est le volume super
réputé avec un casque non on n'est pas
laide hastac max est parti aussi les
ormes
elle m'a d'abord les ae a pris max je
pars ce soir et je reviendrai pas dire
[Musique]
ça à mon cabinet dans une heure je serai
dans une heure oui moi aussi j'y arrive
on arrive tout le monde arrive
demain ça va pas très fort en ce moment
tu sais ma chérie plus riches
c'est un des derniers petits bonheurs
pour des gens en scène j comme un
graphique si la salle est grande depuis
du
vous lui avez donné de plantes j'ai pas
la première des neuf lots 1 avec des
fougères si c'est pour déjeuner non je
te mets les inspections médicales savez
docteur je vais essayer de rencontrer
quelqu'un non au possible
pourquoi tout au plus tu peux crier son
problème et mozart la victoire
qui séduit un ami n'importe quoi je vais
chanter au sud
non
ça me fait du bien de le voir en concert
[Applaudissements]
j'irai quand tu as à quoi la photo de la
carte vitale
vous voulez qu'on en parle un peu